the artist is a film that you're going
to hear a lot about more than likely you
already have and that's one of the
reasons why I sought it out when I went
to New York a few weeks back I saw it at
the Angelika Film Center I haven't got a
chance to review it until now but I'm
glad I waited because I got to Mull the
film over in my head a little bit and I
got to kind of cement my thoughts on the
film it'll be a lot easier for me to
explain how I feel about it the artist
is a silent film made in 2011 plays just
like the old silent films it's even in
4x3 full screen frame which is you know
unheard of nowadays it's fully in black
and white almost entirely just music and
you know you get the title cards what
people are saying it's about an actor
and an aspiring actress and the dawn of
the talkies the main actor in this film
is very much in his silent movies and
when the talkies come he doesn't want
any part of it he thinks that that is
just going to be you know like a stupid
phase that will eventually die out and
that silent films is where the real art
is and of course as we know that's not
how it goes and things get really hard
for him to survive and the aspiring
actress who he met on one of his silent
films she's into the talkies and and she
likes that and she becomes very popular
and he doesn't
a lot of people are saying this is one
of the best movies of the year if not
the best movie of the year I think it's
excellent film and it's really a film
for hardcore film lovers or people who
just really love older films but if
you're just an average viewer and you
have no idea of this movies about going
in definitely might be a little taken
aback by but hopefully you'll enjoy it
the actors in this movie are able to
portray that old style of acting you
know everything is over exaggerated a
lot and they're very good at it and I
think I could maybe even show this movie
to someone and trick them into thinking
that it was an older film it's very very
good at recreating that older style
there's something intriguing about this
movie and it's got something about it
that kind of sticks with you after after
you see it and it makes you interested
in maybe seeing it again it goes without
saying that the musical score is
wonderful and this is a perfect
opportunity for a composer to shine
because you know hey would you like to
compose a film where basically your
music is the only thing we hear yeah
definitely happy that'll be a good
opportunity for me to shine also great
in this movie is the dancing there are
some really good dance numbers in this
movie and some really catchy tunes also
I don't know if you guys knew but I'm
kind of a dancer myself and so I really
appreciate a lot of the dancing
sequences in this movie yeah
there really is anything about the movie
that I can't recommend everything is
strong the directing the acting the way
the story is told is a little different
too because I've never really seen a
movie with a plot like this and
obviously very rarely do we get silent
films nowadays in fact I yeah it doesn't
really happen after I first saw it I
originally I was going to give the
artist a B+ but after thinking about a
little bit and how you know the movie
affected me I'm going to give it a a - I
think it's a good film
let me know down in Stockman Square
what's your favorite black-and-white
movie - personally twelve Angry Men
classic though if you liked this review
you can subscribe to my channel and get
stupid eyes